and you would sir Peter the pipe and
describ welcome to PewDiePie quiz 2016 B
we did the first quest and it was a load
of horseshit but let's find out how well
do you know PewDiePie can you may get my
root name right okay first question what
is
PewDiePie's home country Japan sweets
Swedish pretty sure it's Sweden but I
would [ __ ] if I know
or Brighton why I guess Swedish correct
Felix is from Swedish
oh yeah muhfucka okay number two
what's the name of pewdiepies girlfriend
let's see if I can remember this
could it be jack skin Jack skeptic I
think you should change his name to that
edgert yeah you wish
I bet you wish that I bet you wish [ __ ]
cry or Poots is single game where is
Marzia alright just cuz uh
edgert is on the screen I'm gonna go
with that good correct what forever
alone boots cannot get a girlfriend
moving on three how long has Felix been
doing YouTube for too long 21 days 59
months that's probably it
or 884 yeah it's I'm gonna have to go
with a 59 months cause that's the
problem wrong it's been 84 yes okay
number four what does PewDiePie call his
Reich what the [ __ ] is this what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] oh we have the left
testicle in the last game so I guess it
makes sense
doctor cramps sergeant herpes or
revenant throat gonorrhea I can click on
throat gonorrhea Oh for [ __ ] sake
that's disgusting why would you do that
I don't need info on throat gonorrhea
thank you very much but I guess I'll I
guess I'll go with dr. crab he's right
testicle it's named Ken
how do they know don't tell Ken okay
I mean don't tell my team where it is
PewDiePie live Japan Swedish [ __ ] sake
or Brighton oh I can't even [ __ ]
select Brighton [ __ ] you uh Swedish
wrong Peter pi is homeless that's why
the god who [ __ ] make this piece of
[ __ ] listen YouTube you could just not
pay as well as people think and if
you're homeless there's nothing wrong
with that and I want you all to know
that there's no shame in playing that
homeless game alright moving up can
PewDiePie outrun a lion what the [ __ ] is
this questions uh yes correct
pew pew pew pi PI is actually fast from
running away from all the bigger boys at
school is one of my old classmates
making this [ __ ] game Jesus crying
seven did Peter pile you I'm not even
gonna read that out even go to school
yes no he went but was not allowed on
the grounds yes
he clearly never went to school it's
pretty obvious getting really [ __ ]
tired of my own [ __ ] face all right
[ __ ] you Peter pie it's pretty obvious
since the one who can't even [ __ ]
spell anything [ __ ] you what can pierce
pencho oh these guys uh a lot hahaha 700
I don't even know what that is I don't
what is that in kilos a bag of sugar I
can definitely bench a bag of sugar but
I'm gonna go with a lot correct
pills cannot lift his own arms for [ __ ]
sake I swear to god this what is pube
defy see what is what is PewDiePie
favorite band
in Lincoln Park Nickelback or nickel
Park nickel Park sounds [ __ ] awesome
I'm gonna have to go with nickel I'm
wrong even Nick even nice Club a nice
Club bag is too good for him what does
that mean
[ __ ] you what does that mean is
correct evidence suggests that during
the closing stages of World War two
Hitler was in fact spotted screaming
into a room step into a webcam for views
and attention it is theorized that
Hitler was in fact PewDiePie wearing a
mustache because he cannot grow one
bonus wound who is the most subscribed
youtuber we got this one this one this
one or this one I don't know which one
points to purify or which one points to
whatever the [ __ ] else but I'm just
gonna go with the Sweden Sweden Swing
one goolah 'du left off
kinky lana COFF COFF allah the pinky
bonnet Allah dhul it off it's ready god
I'll [ __ ] kill you I'll find this guy
who makes these [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
puzzles or quizzes and I will find you
and I will fist you alright thanks for
watching this video leave a like if you
enjoyed it from them and no I will not
do more depending [ __ ] you and that's it
for now as always stay awesome I am the
more subscribe [ __ ] on YouTube everyone
knows this say it say my name that's
right
DG colleague
you what do you think of the question so
far yeah I'll tell you what I think of
the [ __ ] questions
they are awesome or they suck well they
suck
Abbi